all right getting this to you a little
later today than i actually intended i
helped my mom build a shed yesterday and
it kind of wiped me out so i slept for
about 16 hours
so now i'm getting this to you i'm gonna
get you tomorrow's video a little
earlier so be sure to check it out
look for it uh click the bell i've been
getting a lot of reports of people like
youtube's not letting me know that you
released a video yes youtube being
stupid but now let the horror movie
marathon begin
scream so scream came out in 1996
directed by wes craven
and it i feel like i'm starting out on
top cause scream
the scream movies are my yearly
tradition
october hits i watch all the scream
movies people have their horror movie
traditions
scream is mine because scream is a
horror movie but it's also a
celebration of horror movies and plus i
let's face it i was randy from scream
when i was in high school so
movie just kind of clicked with me see
for a while horror movies slasher movies
they became supernatural michael myers
started out as
just a crazy guy with a knife that's who
he was then halloween two on i mean
the moment he takes a couple slugs to
the eyeballs in halloween too i was like
you're now supernatural you just kind of
lived through that jason vary is
supernatural freddy supernatural
ghostface
wasn't ghostface it's clear this is just
somebody with a mask who's stalking
people and stabbing them takes it back
to the original halloween but cherry on
top
it's also a mystery from the get-go the
movie lets you know that you're supposed
to
figure out who this killer is and if you
don't get it by then there's this scene
where sydney prescott all our friends
they're all sitting around
and they're talking about like ooh maybe
you did are you saying that i killed her
and that's what kept me engaged with
scream from the get-go and when the
sequels were coming out i was always
looking forward to the fact
like who's it gonna be this time after
scream it's like
other movies wanted to be screamed
instead of these supernatural killers
you still had movies like that
but there was this whole sub genre of
movies like
urban legend i know what you did last
summer all these movies where it was
like no it's a real
person in a costume but you're supposed
to guess who it is though i know what
you did last summer kind of went a
different way with it
upon its execution but still and i
remember talking with one of my friend's
girlfriends and she was like yeah scream
scared the hell out of me
because i know jason isn't real i know
freddy krueger isn't real
but scream was just that's a that's a
crazy person in your high school killing
people that [ __ ] could happen
it was this crazy world of antitrust and
realism it's not the only thing that
brought scream down to the level of
believability it being the celebration
of horror movies they talk about horror
movies in this movie
they watch halloween when they're all
hanging out at their party
which scream totally became the 90s high
school hangout party movie
absolutely but the fact that these
horror movies exist
in this movie makes it feel more real
also it makes it feel like it doesn't
take place in this other world this
fictional movie world it takes place in
your world the real world where they
watch and enjoy horror movies
these horror movies that you know exist
they're not these fake ass made up
horror movies that they just throw out
there for the sake of trying to avoid
copyright now they talk about and
reference halloween texas chainsaw
massacre
the howling just made it feel more real
but the fact that it has so much energy
and has so much
fun with its premise that's what keeps
me coming back there are a lot of
mysteries that are great movies but once
you
know the answer once you get to the end
once you know
the answer to the mystery you're like
all right well that was kind of the
thing it was all riding on and now i
know and now i don't
really feel like i have to see the movie
a hundred times scream is so much
90s movie fun i've watched the movie of
all the movies i'm
probably going to review in the course
of this month
scream is the one i have seen the most
hands down it's a blast it's fun it's
gory it's creepy in parts we gotta talk
about nev campbell nev campbell
is the lead in scream and when i think
of
charismatic actors that completely carry
a horror movie or a horror movie
franchise
nev campbell is she is the standard
jamie lee curtis was the scream queen
back in the day but nev campbell
was the scream queen quite literally
of the 90s she's clever witty vulnerable
fights back
which i mean fighting back against ghost
face
ghost face and scream is dope a bit of a
clod let's
face it always slashing at people and
the person moves and like nope still
going hit the door running after someone
when they reach for the fridge
it's not like ghost face was like hey
let me duck under the freezer door
that's clearly gonna hit me in the face
don't you would swear ghostface doesn't
actually want to kill
somebody in such a common way as a knife
maybe ghostface is just waiting for
tatum to crawl through
the garage door so we can like hey
that's way more interesting than a knife
thank goodness i let her dodge my swings
and took all those hits because
otherwise she would have died in a very
stupid fashion this mainly if i have a
gripe about scream it's that
ghost face is just a bit of an idiot no
matter who ghost face is it's like
ghost face doesn't know how to fight
actually and also i gotta say
scream has bar none
some of the best pacing i have seen
in a horror movie period scream is
almost two hours long feels like an
hour and a half max it has excellent
pacing superb energy it keeps that
momentum going
all the way to the end of the movie if
you haven't seen scream by now i've
i'm baffled it's a horror movie with
comedy but it's comedy
because of some of the cynicism of
characters
some of the ironic things some
characters say but it feels like
real interaction and that's the best
kind of comedy in a movie like this it's
comedy that doesn't make
the movie a comedy but it's a certain
energy that's interjected into it that
makes it just a little more fun a little
more enjoyable
it's a must for horror movie fans this
movie was made
for horror movie fans scream absolutely
is
awesome tacular
so scream the original scream have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your
favorite halloween tradition you know
that movie where you're like
october gotta watch this movie whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you